[Applause]
these are scenes captured at a stadium
in Guinea's Capital Connor cray in
September 2009 tens of thousands of
people were gathered to protest the
military regime and presidency of Musa
dadis Kamara
Security Forces blocked off exits fired
tear gas
and then opened fire on the crowds
killing at least 150 people
many were victims of mass rape in the
hours that followed
this is the photo of my brother who died
and this woman she's a rape victim who
died in 2018. there are many victims who
died after the events because they
contracted HIV
while the trial of the 11 men accused of
masterminding the events on the day got
underway in September 2022 13 years
after the fact it's a trial that's faced
several delays
the delays are due to lawyers fees
because the lawyers felt there was a
financial shortfall as they had to work
on this case three days a week for eight
months the state has got to provide a
small subsidy to lawyers to compensate
them as the trial continues
the former president continues to deny
any responsibility for the incident and
blames uncontrollable Security Forces as
well as his former advisor for what
happened
the NGO dedicated to honoring the
victims and bringing the perpetrators to
justice is hopeful there'll be no more
delays
also this trial is the accomplishment of
all the fights we started 13 years ago
to seek Justice and bring reparation to
the victims seeing the trial on the
September 28th case resume really gives
us a feeling of accomplishment Human
Rights Watch says its research points to
a government cover-up with allegations
bodies removed from morgues were buried
in Mass Graves to conceal the scale of
what unfolded
14 years on and many families are yet to
find the remains of their loved ones
Michael Apple Al Jazeera